ร้านอาหาร
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนก็ดีค่ะนักเรียนค่ะวันนี้ครู
เอ๋หน้าใกล้ๆจะได้หน้าตัวโตๆมันผู้หญิง
ได้ขนาดเดียวกับผู้หญิงแชร์สกรีนให้มัน
ใหญ่ๆหน่อยนะคะคุณได้ค่ะนักเรียนจะได้
เห็นเราสัตว์
หน้าได้แล้วค่ะครูเองได้ค่ะคู่หญิงแม่วัน
นี้วันอะไรคะกูผู้หญิงมีสีเหลืองวัน
จันทร์ค่ะ
นี้วันจันทร์ใช่ค่ะวันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะครูหญิงวันที่
13 ค่ะดีเดือนอะไรคะ
เดินเดือนมิถุนายนเดือนมิถุนายน
เมื่อปีพศอะไรคะ
2565 อันเนี่ยบอกว่าทำไมเราสลับกันถามปี
คศอะไรคะ 2,000
22 ค่ะ
2022 แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูเอ๋
ก่อนนะคะ
มาย 3 โมง 12 นาทีน
บ่าย 3 โมง 12 นาที
ใช่ค่ะค่ะโอเคเคลียร์ค่ะ
บ๊ายบายเดียวยังๆๆวันนี้มาเสร็จแล้ว
เคลียร์หมายถึงว่าลบที่เขียนไปค่ะไม่ๆไม่
ใช่เคลียร์วีดีโอนี้ค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงกู
เองม้วนผมได้ขบวนได้เพราะว่าครูหญิงจะตอน
เวลาที่ครูเอ๋ม้วนผมกลิ่นกะส่ำแม้ว่าวัน
นี้มีเกมอะไรให้ครูเอ๋เล่นครับผมกูเอก
เป็นเป็ดอยู่ข้างนี้สวยค่ะแฟชั่นโอเคไม่
ม้วนละ
วันนี้มีเกมใช่ค่ะครูหญิงจะมีรูปอยู่ใน
สี่เหลี่ยมเนี่ยอาจจะเป็นรูป
อ้าวจริงกูเองไม่เห็นนะแต่ว่านี้คุณนกตัว
อย่างนะคะแต่เว้นวันใช่แต่ผู้หญิงนะจะปิด
ปิดๆปิดเอาไว้ให้ครูเอ๋เนี่ย
ดูดู
นิดหน่อยมาหาออกไม่ต้องให้ครูเห็นเรื่อง
เลือกเลือกแล้วเปิด
มายค่ะพวกกูเอกเก่งมากแบบนั้นไม่โอเค
เพราะว่าคลิปก่อนก่อนๆกูเอนดูแล้วก็เลือก
แล้วเปิดนะคะๆแล้วพบกันนะฮะฮะ
วันนี้ครูหญิงมีรูปแล้วก็ปิดปิดปิดเปิด
นิดหน่อยใช่ค่ะให้ครู a เนี่ยดู
หืแล้วดู
ยังๆๆหนึ่งเนี่ยดู
2i คู๋เนี่ยฟังขอใช้ป่าตาดูแล้วก็หู
ฟัง
ฟังแล้วก็ 3 คู่เอกก็คิดว่า
เอกใช่ไหมโค้ชเอ๋เอ๋เอ๋ก็คิดว่ารูปที่ครู
หญิงให้ดูเนี่ยคือรูปของอะไรหูแปลว่าต้อง
ยากใช่ไหมผู้หญิงน่ะไม่ยากค่ะครูหญิง
เนี่ยใจดีนี้โอเคเพราะครูหญิงมากลองดู
ต้องฟังต่อ
ไปค่ะค่ะดูแล้วก็เห็นตอบเลยได้ไหมคะไม่
ได้ค่ะค่ะคุณเอ๋ต้องดูแล้วก็ฟังต้องดูฟัง
2 อย่างอ่ะดูห้ามพูดใช่มั้ยฟังค่ะห้าม
พูดแล้วก็ 3 พูดไปค่ะครูเอ๋เก่งมากค่ะ
โอเคเราไปดูเริ่มเลยค่ะครูเอ๋เดี๋ยวขอผู้
หญิงขยะไปนี่ยังอยู่เลยนะอะไร
ผู้หญิงขยับค่ะอย่างเนี่ยนี่แรกค่ะรูปนี้
ครู S ดูดู
นะเคยเห็นแล้วใช่ไหม
เห็นคุยเห็นเห็นสีเขียวกับสีเหลือง
อันนี้สีเขียวอะดิสีเหลืองให้ค่ะค่ะวงโขง
คงคงตัวอะไรอ่ะหากดูแลไม่
ค่ะรูปทั้งหมดเนี่ยเป็นสถานที่ค่ะค่ะดู
แอบดูนะคะรูปที่ 2 กเว็บฟังนะฟังดูเสร็จ
แล้วนะคะฟังสถานที่นี้เนี่ยสนุก
เบียร์เห็นไหมคนในรูปนี้เนี่ยทุกคนอย่า
แยกสนุกๆทุกคนสนุกอยู่ในสวนโอ้โอ๋
อันนี้ไงมีต้นไม้มีต้นไม้ผู้หญิงน่ะต้น
ไม้อ่าแล้วมีหญ้าหญ้าโอ้ทุกคนกำลังสนุกๆ
ในสวนอะไรค่ะงั้นครูเอ๋เนี่ยดูแล้ว
ฟังแล้วตัวเองคิดว่ารูปนี้เนี่ยสถานที่
คือที่ไหนก็สนุกแล้วก็มีสวนสวนสนุกค่ะสวน
สนุกไปดูค่ะนักเรียนว่าครู as จะถูกหรือ
ผิดสวนสนุกสวนสนุกสวนสนุกค่ะนะคะเรียนสวน
สนุกค่ะเย่อันนี้เนี่ยคือเครื่องเล่นใช่
ไหมกูเอ๋ถ้าไม่ใช่ชื่ออะไรขึ้นเล่นนะน่า
จะโรลเลอร์โคสเตอร์ her ครูหญิง
นะเล่นหมาย
ทำไม
ทำไมคะภาษาสัตว์ว่า
มันถุงมันสูงใช่มะนักมันเร็วด้วยนะ
คะเห็นนางไหมเอ๋กลัวมาก
ท้องนั่งคุยต้องหลับตาแล้วก็
หรอก
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่ไหวค่ะอ่ะนะหรือกับครูเอ๋ไม่
ชอบนะคะ
เป็นครูหญิงกับครูเอกก็คิดสวนไม่สนุกสิ
สนุกจะไม่เล่นไงหนูไปแต่ไม่เล่นไม่เล่นนะ
คะเพราะโรลเลอร์โคสเตอร์นะคะใส่กะ
โรลเลอร์โคสเตอร์อยู่ในสวนสนุกเกร็งเก่ง
มากให้ไปเลยค่ะ 1 คะแนนวันนี้วันจันทร์
เนาะเอาสีเหลืองไปนะคะ
มีอีกไหมหมดแล้วค่ะถ้าเบรคค่ะปะ
ครู S ดูเห็นไหมเห็นอะไรเห็นเป็นกลมกลมๆ
เหมือนท่อ
สีฟ้าดูสีเหมือนอันนี้สีฟ้าสีสาใช่ไหมสี
ฟ้าดูไม่ยากเดี๋ยวฟังแล้วจะง่าย
เอ่ออ่ะ
[เพลง]
ตัวท่อเนี่ยที่กูเห็นมันเป็นท่อแหละแต่
ว่าเป็นพ่อของสวนน้ำเล่นสไลด์เดอร์
ค่ะก็เป็นส่วนส่วนน้ำเราเรียกสวนน้ำมีน้ำ
อันนี้ราคานักเรียนผู้หญิงเอ๋ไม่มีตอนนี้
อ้ะมีน้ำนะคะแล้วก็มีสไลเดอร์นะคะทรายครู
เอ๋
ประเทศไทยมีสวนน้ำไหมคะมีค่ะเหลวไปไหมคะ
ไปค่ะไปทำอะไรคะคุณอยู่ที่นี่หรออุ้ยสี
เหมือนกันอีกไม่ค่ะเขาก็สไลเดอร์ไม่คุยไป
นั่งดูค่ะดูเพื่อนเล่นน้ำ
ผู้หญิงโอเคนะคะส่วนน้ำไม่กลัวไม่เจอผู้
หญิงได้เหรอไปสไลด์เดอร์แล้วลงมาถ้า
สไลเดอร์เป็นท่อแบบอ่าโอเคแต่ถ้าสไลเดอร์
ที่แบบเป็นแบบนี้เห็นพี่ไม่มีทอดอดเราไม่
เห็นมั้ยคะใช่รู้มีท่อก็ไม่เอาไม่มีตังค์
ก็อย่างเงี้ยแล้วเราก็สไลด์วุฒิภูมิอัน
นี้ไม่เอานี่กลัวเหมือนกันคะ
เกรกเก่งมากชื่ออุตส่าห์พานะคะต่อไปค่ะ
เอ๋
ไม่เห็นอะไรครับเห็นข้างหลัง
น่าจะผู้ชายหลังข้างหลังน้องมีเสื้อ
กางเกงอารู้ด้วยนะเก่งมากนะลานดูจาก
แฟชั่นค่ะคิดว่ารักผู้ชายผู้ชายใช่ไหมคะ
อะฟังนะคะคุยเดี๋ยวขอผู้หญิงหาสมุดที่ผู้
หญิงเขียนก่อนได้ไหมคะครูเอ๋ๆค่ะ
น่ะเอาแก่
ดูอ่ะ
มาดูว่าในรูปเนี่ยผู้ชายมีกล้องส่องแล้ว
ก็ดูค่ะดูเอกคิดเป็นที่วาดรูปนี้เนี่ย
สถานที่ในรูปนี้เนี่ยคือที่ไหน
ดูเหรอคะดูแล้วก็ไปที่ผู้ชายซิ
ค่ะใหญ่ก็ไม่ได้เนาะ
ขยายใหญ่หรอยเห็นแค่ตอนเนี้ยอยากดูตรงนี้
มันใหญ่ได้มั้ยหน้า
ดุ
เธอต้องตอบเป็นพวกภูเขาอะไรให้เนี่ยไหว้
ค่ะไม่ไม่มีภูเขาไม่มีทะเลไม่มีน้ำตกไม่
มี
อะไรเนี่ย
ครูเอ๋รู้จักภูเขาเนี่ยอ่าไม่ใช่อาเล่ดี
เจไม่ใช่มั๊ยค่ะไม่
ดูเหรอดูว่าเวลาเราไปในที่นี่ที่นี่นะคะ
ที่เนี้ยเราดูเราไปดูดูดูดูดูๆๆคะวัดใช่
ไหมครูเอ๋บอกว่าวัดอ้วนมันก็ไม่เหมือนวัด
น่า
เที่ยวนะไม่เหมือนว่ารู้เองให้หนึ่งคำครู
เอ๋เนี่ย When  Used เสื้อสีขาวว่าซื้อคน
ที่ใส่เสื้อสีนี้สวนสัตว์ 5
สวนสัตว์สวนสัตว์หน้าขอบคุณนะครับขอบคุณ
ที่หินค่ะมากกูอย่าให้กูเอกถูกไงอ่ะไม่
รู้ว่าใช่สวนสอบไหม
ใช่ค่ะ
ว่าเวลาเราอ่ะ
แต่เวลาเราไปสวนสัตว์แล้วก็เป็นดูสัตว์ไง
ไปดูยีราฟ
[เพลง]
20 ไม่มีแต่ยีราฟคะเนี่ยก็อันนี้เป็น
ส่วนของยีราฟไงไอขายไม่ดูดูเสื้อให้เห็น
ตรงเย็นก็ป่าหรือภูเขาไงไม่ใช่ไม่มีไม่มี
ภูเขานะคะครู x เก่งมากค่ะรูปสถานที่ต่อ
ไป
อยู่ค่ะเห็นไหมคะ
สนามกอล์ฟคะไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่สนามกอล์ฟดู
แล้วนะอะไรอ่ะไม่เห็นอะไรล่ะไม่รู้โต๊ะขา
โต๊ะเหรอผู้หญิงโอมให้ก็ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋
อย่างเงี้ย
อะไรอ่ะอันนี้เป็นสนามหญ้าใช่ไหมเป็นต้น
ยากแล้วก็เป็นหินหินหินหินหรอสายๆเดี๋ยว
เขาคุยเดี๋ยวกลับก่อนนะเดี๋ยวมันกดรูปต่อ
ไปไม่ได้นะคะค่ะ
อะไรอ่ะอันนี้นะอันนี้ดูใช่ไหมอ้าวฟังฟัง
สถานที่นี้นะคะพี่เอ๋มีเงียบสงบ
วัดสิ
บอกว่าวัดใช่แพ่งเนี่ยก็วัดทรายหัน
เฮียบแล้วก็สงบด้วยนะแบบมีลมนี่กับ
คนคนใช่ไหมคะผู้ชายผู้หญิงคนเนี่ยจริงๆก็
ไม่ได้มีขนาดน้องสาวสาร
สุสานถึงจริงสุสานสุสานสุสานกำลังคิดเงิน
ระหว่างวัดจะวัดคนก็เยอะทั้งเงียบถูกต้อง
สุสาน
สึกอัดจีน 5 สถานฝรั่งอุดตันทีนะคะสื่อ
สารไปดูว่าให้ไหม
ใช่ฟ้า
[เพลง]
สุสานหรือเปล่าช้านะคะขอทำแบบนี้ได้ว่า
สุสานนะคะสึกสารนะคะหรือว่าจะเป็นคนไทยก็
จะเป็นดินขึ้นมาใช่ไหมครูเอ๋ใช่
ถ้าเป็น Thai  Chinese ก็แบบนี้
อ่านี่คนถ่ายในชนิดแบบนี้ที่นี่ก็มีคนตาย
นะคะสุสาน
สารเก่งมากค่ะครูเอ๋คุณผู้หญิงชิ้นเยอะๆ
นะฮ่าๆๆๆ
ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ดูดู
นะไม่รู้เรื่องเนาะขอดูใกล้ซูมได้ไหมคะ
สูงได้ไหม
มีแต่ก็เมื่อก่อนกูเอ๋ดูใหญ่ๆแล้วพระเอก
เก่งไงเปลี่ยนต้องดูเล็กๆจะได้เข้าใจกู
หญิงนะคะเวลาคุณเองโอเค
เดี๋ยวยังไม่ได้ฟังเลยไม่สั่งได้ไหมไม่
ได้ค่ะ
ถ้าไม่ฟัง 2 คะแนนไหมไม่ส่งคะแนนต้องสั่ง
อ้างไปเที่ยว
โหยนี้มีอะไรบ้างมีแว่นตา
เมสเสจเดี๋ยวนะมีขอขอขอประกามาก่อนนะครับ
มีมีมีแว่นตา
มีโทรศัพท์มีกล้องร้องสองทางไกลมีกล้อง
ถ่ายรูป
มีฟิล์มหมู่หมวด
แผนที่
อินเดียน่าโจนส์หรือเปล่าเนี่ยเราก็ไม่มี
ขวดอะมาเนี่ยกฎขวดน้ำแต่ขวดน้ำนะคะอ่ะอ่า
อะครูเอกคิดว่า
คิดว่าคิดว่า
สนามบินค่ะตัวเองคิดว่าสนามบิน
สนามบิน
ไปดูค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะค่าสนามบินครูเอ๋ประเทศไทยมีสนาม
บินอะไรที่นักเรียนเนี่ยรู้จักสนามบิน
สุวรรณภูมิ
ใจค่ะสนามบินดอนเมือง 2 อย่างใช่ค่ะ
กรุงเทพเนาะจอใกล้ๆกรุงเทพฯนะคะเก่งมาก
คุยยังไม่ผิดเลย
เก่งต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ค่อยได้ให้ดูแล้ว
ขยายใหญ่ๆ TOA รู้
อะไรอ่ะเห็นอ่ะมีใครเห็นผู้หญิงกับผู้ชาย
และผู้หญิง 1 คนแล้วก็ผู้ชายแต่ตรงนี้ดู
ไม่ชัดอ่ะกูหญิง
ต้องผู้เองตรงเนี่ยไม่ชัดไม่ชัดไม่มีผู้
หญิงหารูปไม่เจอกับแป๊บพอเดาได้นะเอ้าไป
ไหนล่ะไม่เห็นไหมเนี่ย
อะไรอ่ะโอเคกูเห็นแล้วนะผู้หญิงหาสาขา
ขยายไม่เจอนะคะไม่ต้องฟังเขาฟังฟังๆ
เรียน
เรียนสมัยเด็กๆเนี่ยเด็กๆเด็กๆเนี่ยเรียน
อยู่มีคนมีผู้ชายผู้หญิงผู้ชายแล้วก็บอก
ไปเลยเด็กก็เรียนแล้วก็จดอา
[เพลง]
จิงๆตอนแรกกูเองคิดว่าอะไรรู้ไหมว่าอะไร
คะคิดว่าเรือตอบนะคะ
ผู้
แปลแปลพ่อตอนแรกคิดว่านี้แล้วก็มีคนสองคน
จะไปที่เรือใหญ่ๆแต่พอมีเด็กเรียนมหา
มีอันนี้อ่าาเก่าๆเออไว้ต้องดูดีๆ
พิพิธภัณฑ์พิพิธภัณฑ์
ในไปดูอะไรเก่าๆๆเรียกก่อน
พิพิธภัณฑ์พิพิธภัณฑ์นะคะดูว่ามันผิดรูป
นี้จะใช่พิพิธภัณฑ์ไหม
เฮ้ยใช่
ในรูปเนี่ยเป็นพิพิธภัณฑ์ไปดูไดโนเสาร์
ใช่ไหมๆไอ้จริงๆก็กี้กูเห็นแว็บนึงแต่กู
เองไม่คิดว่าเป็นอันนี้นะกินอะไร
ไม่ใช่หรอคะครูหญิงกดไอ้นี่ให้กูเอ๋แล้ว
มันกดผิดและพิพิธภัณฑ์นี่ไงพี่ทหารก็จะมี
ป้ายบอกใช่ไหมเด็กๆก็อ่านเหมือนเรียนและ
ผู้หญิงให้กูเห็นแค่เนี๊ยะใช้เอกคิดว่า
เรือ
คิดว่าหรือเรือเหลืออะไรให้ทันอีกเหรอๆ
ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋เก่งมากดูค่ะดูมั้ย
ดูอะไรฮะไหง่แล้วนี่ไง
สีแดงๆเนี่ยนาแดงแดงสวยค่ะ
คุณเอ๋ดูเนี่ยอาจจะยังไม่รู้แต่ถ้าฟังมัน
ไม่เสียวนี้มันไม่ชัดน่ะอยากเห็นตรงนี้
แป๊ปนึงนะคะโอเคปิดตาก่อนขยายเสร็จแล้วบ่
ไม่ๆขยายเมื่อกี้นี้จะผิดอันนี้ค่ะนี้ค่ะ
คุณเอง
ฮะอ่ะก็ยิ่งไม่รู้เลยนะฮ่าๆร้านขาย
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวหรอคะดูเนี่ยจะไม่รู้ไม่เป็นไร
ค่ะลองฟังดูฟัง
บ้านกับแสง Five
แสงไฟในรูปนี้นะคือแสงไป
อันนี้แสงไฟ
สถานที่นี้ในสถานที่นี้เนี่ยเวลาเราไป
เนี่ยเมื่อกี้แสงไฟ 2 จุดไฟแบบนี้เลยค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ดิสโก้เธคหรอคะใช่ดิสโกเธค
ไม่มีแสงไฟแบบนี้ได้โรงหนังไม่ใช่โรงหนัง
โรงละครเออณโรงละครไปดูว่าใช่โรงละครไหว
ถ้าขอแรงว่าใช่
เปิดแค่ผู้หญิงผิดทำไมลืม
ชะเยคองผู้หญิงไอ้ตรงนี้
คือที่บ้านไงกูเอ๋เวลาเราไปดูใช่ไหมตรง
นี้เนี่ยเป็นเวทีณเวทีเดี๋ยวเขาจะเล่น
ละครเวทีมันมีที่ไหนนี้นะคู่เอ๋แจง
ก็ยัง
ไม่ใช่ที่นั่งตรงนี้ก็จะมีวงออเคสตร้าวง
ดนตรี
[เพลง]
โอเคค่ะเก่งมากเคยดื่มน้ำก่อนได้นะคะ
ประเทศไทยมีไหมคะโรงละครเนี่ย
มีค่านี้เนาะกูเอกก็เก่งบ้านมีโรงละครของ
ประเทศไทยแล้วก็ลงละครเอกชนค่ะติดต่อไป
ค่ะคู๋
ดู
โรงเรียนนะคะเล็กจังเลย
ก็ต้องดูเล็กๆไม่พูดเอ๋ใหญ่ๆไม่ดูใหญ่ๆ
รู้ยังไงก็รู้แล้วไหมจะบอกว่ารู้แล้วตั้ง
แต่
ฟังก่อนค่ะ
ก็ผู้หญิงสไบอะไร
ผู้หญิงลองหู
ฟัง
ก็คือฟัง
อะไรครับครูเอ๋โบสถ์ค่ะโบสถ์นะคลิป
โบสถ์ศาสนาคริสต์เพราะว่าศาสนาพุทธก็มี
โบสถ์นะคะ
ไปดูว่าจะใช่โบสถ์ไหม
ใช่บทนิยายข้างบน
เนื้อเพลงตรงนี้เป็นทางเดินใช่ไหมที่โทร
หาเห็นแล้วก็เป็นเก้าอี้นะคะกูเอกกำลัง
คิดระหว่างโรงเรียนกับโบสถ์นะคะแต่ถ้ากู S
ดูดีๆครับเราจะเข้าใจต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ค่ะ
ค่ะ
ดู
ผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงเนี่ยนั่งใส่นั่งสีแดง
นั่งหันหลังใช่ไหมในรูปแล้วก็มีเสื้อน่ะ
สีแดงสีแดง
ฟังค่ะอันนี้ไม่รู้จริงๆทั้ง
แฮล์มถ่ายรูป
อ้าว
แห้งดูห้ามถ่ายรูปภาพถ่ายรูปมี 2 ที่
โรงพยาบาล
กับโรงหนังจะ
พูดอะไรเธอ
เพลงพยาบาลเนาะโรงพยาบาลเกาะเวลาเราไม่
สบายแล้วก็โรงหนังใช่ไหมเวลาเราไปที่นี่
แล้วก็มีเก้าอี้นั่งเก้าอี้นั่งไปดู
Jurassic ปลา Jurassic  World  Harry
Potter โรงหนังถ่ายรูป
ไม่เป็นไรโรงพยาลงหนังโปรเอบอกว่าโรงหนัง
ไม่ใช่คุณ
อีก 1 ครั้ง
โรงพยาบาลอะครูเอบอกว่าโรงพยาบาลไม่ใช่
เหมือนกันล่ะต่อไปดูค่ะว่าใช่โรงพยาบาล
ไหม
พยาบาล
3 แต้มดีแล้ว
ไม่รู้ไหมสถานที่นี้เรียกว่าอะไร
คนไทยเล่นแกลอรี่เหมือนกันน่ะขายคนไทยบาง
ครั้งอาจจะเรียกหอศิลป์ไงขอศิลปอาชาใช่
มั้ยหอศิลป์ไปดู
รูปนะคะรูปวาด
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยคิดว่าทำไมครูหญิงไม่เอา
เนี่ยก็โทษนะถ้าครูหญิงเอาแบบนี้แบบนี้
น่ะซื้อ R  R แบบนี้ครูเอ๋จะคิดได้
ก็มันง่ายไงกูเอกเตะนี่ไงกูหญิงนึกว่า
เวลาครูเห็นว่าห้ามถ่ายรูปเพจจะคิดถึงรูป
วาดโมนาลิซ่าไงเวลามีรูปวาดของโมนาลิซ่า
เค้าจะห้ามถ่ายรูปไปไหนดูสิดูสิห้ามถ่าย
รูปไงห้ามถ่ายไม่แต่กูไม่ดูข้างในอ๋ออ๋อ
กูเองไม่ได้ดูรูปอันนี้รู้เห
รอเราไปดูหนัง
BatMan ดูหนังสไปเดอร์แมนเค้าก็ห้ามถ่าย
รูปเวลาไปโรงพยาบาลก็ห้ามถ่ายรูปเวลาไปหอ
ศิลป์ครูเอกก็เห็นคนถ่ายรูป
แต่บางครั้งไง
ขอสินธ์และถ่ายรูป
ฟรีและรู้ไม่แพง
ต่อไปค่ะครูเอกไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรดูค่ะดู
หน้าต่างประตูศรีปาดค่ะหน้าต่างใช่ไหมคะ
บียังระเบียงอันนี้ระเบียงเตียง
ดูนะฟังฟังนะฟัง
นอนโรงขอแรง
[เพลง]
ครูเอ๋บอกว่าว่าโรงแรมสมัยโรงแรมเนี่ยก็
จะมี 5 ดาวมีดาว 5 ดาวโรงแรม
ผิดค่ะไม่ใช่โรงแรมมันเบสิคเกินไปโรงแรม
นอน
ไม่ใช่เรานอนไม่ใช่ครูหญิงผู้หญิงไม่ใช่
ครูเอ๋นอน
ใครนอนล่ะเห็นนอนที่ไหน
นอนที่บ้านนครนอนที่บ้านเราเนี่ยนอนที่
บ้านนอนคอนโดนอน Apartment เอาถ้าไม่ใช่
โรงแรมโรงพยาบาลเนาะ
x พยาบาลไม่มีโรงแรมไม่มีโรงพยาบาลนอน
หรอ
ไม่ใช่บ้านของเราเราเป็นคนธรรมดาอ่าปรา
ที่ชาร์จ
อัตลาสหวังว่าง่ายอะพระราชวัง
พระราชวังใช่ไหมกูจะไปถึงบ้านนอกบ้านของ
ในหลวง
ราชินีในบ้านของราชินีนะคะพระราชวังพระ
ราชวังใช่ไหมเห็นก็นอกเฉลยแล้วกัน
222 พระราชวัง
ใช่ค่ะแต่ไม่ใช่ของไทยนะอังกฤษผู้หญิงไม่
ให้ดูอันนี่เข้าใจ
คุยขอโทษนะครูหญิงให้ดูแค่ตรงนี้กูเอกก็
คิดโรงแรมอะไรก็ได้
พระราชวังค่ะดีก็น่าจะเป็นพระราชวัง
บักกิงแฮมมั้ยน่าจะ
พระ
บรมมหาราชวังใช่ไหมโอ้ของไทยมันจะเหมือน
วัดและก็เลยไม่หามานะคะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋อ่ะ
ดู
เห็นอะไรเห็นทะเล
เห็นเขาใกล้ๆทะเลเห็นอะไรไม่รู้
ไม่ได้ไหมค่ะประภาคาร
ฟังก่อนเรือ
ท่า
เทียบท่าเรือ
ท่าเรือก็คืนที่ที่เรือขับมาจอดภาย
ท่าเรือไปดูนะคะว่าใช้ท่าเรือไหม
กินต่อไปว่าใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่ก็ได้ 1
2  3
ประภาคารโอ๊ยคุยเองก็กูเองพูดคนแรกแปลว่า
ปรับอาจค้าหน้าพูดห๊ะเปลี่ยนทำไมอ่ะ
แต่เราพาคอนราคาถ้าแบบโอยดูเรืองใช่หรอ
กูเองตอบประภาคารก่อนน่ะแล้วคุณ
ครูเอ๋เปลี่ยนเองอ่ะต่อไปกับครูเอ๋ผู้
หญิงซิกซะ
ดูค่ะอะไรไม่เห็นเลขก็เห็น
ไอ้ออกสินใจร้ายมากเลยนะนี่ไงเห็นไหม
โอเคใจเย็นๆใจเย็นๆใจเย็นๆฟังก่อนฟังก่อน
ดูแล้วนะคะฟังประชุม
ประชุมที่ราดสถานีรัฐสภา
รัฐสภาไปดูนะคะว่าใช่ไหม
คะเอกครับฐาน
อ่า
อันนี้คือรัฐสภานทุประเทศนี้มีนะคะอ่าต่อ
ไปค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงลืมให้คะแนน
หือ
ประภาคารอาจารย์เสียใจถ้าเกิดดูอ่ะเล็กๆ
ตอบได้ไหมคะเดี๋ยวทำก่อนฟังก่อนเด็กๆเด็ก
ๆคิดว่าสถานที่นี้คือที่ไหน
เอ่อ
ตัวไทยใช่ไหมคะภาษาไทยพิพิธภัณฑ์สัตว์น้ำ
พิพิธภัณฑ์สัตว์น้ำหรือว่าบางครั้งคนไทย
ก็พูดเอาก็เรียบม.จ.อาจจะไปดูค่ะ
ใครใครค่ะเก๋ครูเก๋รู้จักอันนี้รู้จัก
อะไรคะค้างฉลาม
เก่งว่าเห็นไหมบังกันคุยอีกก็ให้ดูถ้าคุย
แค่มือดิ 4 คู่เอกจะไม่รู้
ไม่ได้ไงคุยมีเด็กๆแล้วนะคะต่อไปค่ะครู
เอ๋
โอ๊ยอันนี้ไม่รู้ล่ะมันต้นไม้ใช่ไหมถ้ากู
a ฟังเนี่ยคิดว่าครูเอกรู้อันนี้ดูไปนะ
คะมีต้นไม้
จ่ายอ่ะฟัง
แดรกคูล่า
ปราสาทหินรสาส
แราสาท You ค่ะ
ไซส์ขอบ
ปราสาท
ปราสาทก็อยู่ส่วนใหญ่จะอยู่บนภูเขาเนาะ
เอาไว้ดูเหมือนกันนะคะคล้ายๆประภาสารหนัง
x เก่งมากสิ่งคิดว่าน่าจะมีอีกนะมีอีก
ไหม 2 เท่านั้นหมดเลยโอเคได้ครูเอ๋ดูนะคะ
เห็นไหมอ่า
หรอกฟังเปล่าก่อนฟังก่อนพระจันทร์เสี้ยว
ก็เข้าใจไหมอันนี้เป็นพระจันทร์เสี้ยว
หากต้องมีดาวด้วย
ทรายเอาให้ดูพระจันทร์เสี้ยวไงไม่ว่าไม่
ให้ดูดาวที่มีดาว
ครูคิดว่าสถานที่นี้คือที่ไหน
มัสยิดค่ะ
มัสยิดนะคะบางทีพูดสุเหร่าเหมือนกันเนาะ
ในพาสในไทยนะคะ
มัสยิดสุเหร่า
ใจทางเก่งมาอันนี้ศาสนาอะไร
ศาสนา
อิสลามอิสลาม
[ปรบมือ]
สุดท้ายแล้วคาคู๋
ต่อไปเห็นเหมือนควันใช่มั้ยมีความแล้วก็
มีกล่องอะไรก็ไม่รู้โรงงานหรือเรือนฝั่ง
แดงเดี๋ยวฟังคำไหว้น่าจะรู้นะคะพี่เอกก็
ถูกเขาถูกให้คะแนนเขาก่อนนะคะอ่ะ
มีเรื่องจัด
เครื่องจัดสมัยนี้เป็นเรื่องจักตอบเลยค่ะ
ตอบว่าที่ไหนคะโรงงานอุตสาหกรรมหูยาวไม้
สั้นๆก็ได้ค่ะโรงงานไปรู้ว่าใช่โรงงานไหม
ใช่ค่ะอยู่
อาคาร
ครูเอได้ทั้งหมด 14 คะแนน
จากทั้งหมด 16
ข้อนะคะเก่งว่าง
คุยผิด 3 ไม่ใช่หรอผิด 2 ไม่ใช่หรอเก็บ
แกลอรี่
กับประภาคารทาง 2 หรอคะใส่ค่ะ
ชายน้อง
ฐานที่เค้าก็ไม่รู้ตอนนักเรียนถูกหรือ
เปล่าไม่เปลี่ยนยังไงครูเอ๋ดูแล้วก็ต่อ
ประภาคารพร้อมฟังเรือเปลี่ยน
โหแล้วไม่ดีนะนะฮะก็วันนี้แต่ว่าวันนี้
หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะเดี๋ยวเราไปเจอกันใหม่ใน
วีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีซอ
บ๊ายบาย